hey 42 here imagine this
you walk into the nearest pharmacy
because you're feeling a little bit
under the weather
but instead of giving you a lozenger for
your sore throat or
a tube appointment for your weird rash
or some pills for your persistent
headache
the chemist passes you a spade and
suggests you dig up your recently
deceased grandmother
that might not sound like the most
obvious prescription under the
circumstances
well unless your local branch of boots
is run by jeffrey dahmer
but for hundreds of years corpse
medicine
the use of human body parts to cure
various ailments
was a very common thing indeed and the
question
on everyone's minds wasn't so much
should we eat people
but who should we eat and which limb
will benefit me the most
even leonardo da vinci wasn't averse to
a spot of corpse munching
we preserve our life with the death of
others he's quoted as saying
in a dead thing incensed life remains
which when it is reunited with the
stomachs
of the living regains sensitive and
intellectual life and 16th century swiss
physician
paracelsus otherwise known as the father
of toxicology
certainly would have agreed with him
believing that in order to cure a
condition
you had to treat it with something
similar for instance
if you had a toothache you could simply
touch a corpse's tooth
to your own tooth and the pain would go
away
or if you had a headache you could snack
on a bit of ground up skull
and you'd be right as rain in no time
i'm told skull is very moorish
over the next few centuries many corpse
medicine practitioners
followed paracelsus's lead although
sometimes the parts of the corpse used
had no relation at all to the ailments
they were supposed to cure
queen elizabeth the first treated her
smallpox scars
by rubbing human fat over her face
coughing water that's literally water
scooped out of a coffin
was used for warts and cataracts were
dealt with
by blowing powdered human excrement into
the eyes
english physician george thompson was
particularly confident in his cure for
hemorrhoids
which involved liberal quantities of
sweat from a dying man
or for particularly serious cases to
touch the piles with a
severed hand apparently this would clear
up your bum grapes no
problem but i do recommend giving your
corpse hand a good wash
before using it for anything else
luckily
treatments have progressed significantly
since then and you won't have to snack
on a bit of corpse to prevent your hair
loss
these days with the super simple
treatment offered by keeps
who've kindly sponsored today's video i
have a good friend
who started to struggle with hair loss
in his twenties
and truthfully it really got him down
and he's not alone did you know two out
of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness
by the time they're 35 but the best
thing you can do to prevent hair loss
is take the initiative now and do
something about it whilst you still have
hair left
in the past you had to go to the
doctor's office for a hair loss
prescription
but now thanks to keeps you can visit an
online doctor and get the medication you
need
delivered directly to your door i really
like keeps because it makes treatment
super easy by delivering your hair loss
medication
every three months so you can say
goodbye to awkward doctor visits and
waiting in pharmacy checkout lines
if you're like me you're probably not
ready to lose hair
just yet but prevention is key the
faster you act the faster you'll see
results
and the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair you'll save
so if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it
for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash
42 or click the link in the description
to receive 50
off your first order so where did all
this necro lunacy come from
in the first place well in those days
spirit was thought to be the thing that
linked
body and soul with body parts containing
the spirit of the corpse
they were taken from it was also forced
that blood carried the soul
and as such fresh blood was considered
to be particularly
potent but the culture of corpse
medicine throughout europe
has its roots in ancient rome
particularly the blood clothing bits
ancient roman doctors thought that by
drinking blood straight from a freshly
croaked gladiator
it was possible to absorb the vitality
of these young men
who up until a few seconds before they'd
been horribly murdered
had been fit and strung this was
supposed to be particularly good for
epilepsy and sufferers would sometimes
crowd a falling gladiator
in order to suck the living blood from
his wounds
but if you find still warm blood sucked
directly from the veins
to be a little bit off-putting i'm told
some people can be a little bit
squeamish about those things
then i have just a thing for you in a
new section i'm going to call
42's corpse recipes meals to die for
first up blood jam perfect with a thick
slice of toast and a mug of tea
this recipe was kindly provided by a
17th century franciscan apothecary
thanks for writing into the channel step
1 take blood from persons
of warm moist temperament such as those
of a blotchy red complexion
and rather plump of build step 2
let it dry into a sticky mask step 3
place it upon a flat smooth table of
soft wood
and cut it into thin little slices
allowing its watery part
to drip away when it is no longer
dripping
place it on a stove on the same table
and stir
it to a batter with a knife step 4
when it is absolutely dry place it
immediately in a very warm bronze mortar
and pound it forcing it through a sieve
of finest silk
when it has all been sieved seal it in a
glass jar
renew it in the spring of every year
sounds delightful doesn't it
let's see you top that one paul
hollywood it was
generally believed corpse medicine was
most effective
if the person in question had died
violently
paracelsus once wrote that after a man
was executed his
vital spirits would burst forth from the
circumference of the bone
but as most of the poor couldn't afford
the prices of the top quality body bits
sold in apothecaries they had to
improvise
in the late 19th century crowds of
epileptics
would gather at scaffolds during
executions
using cubs to catch blood from recently
decapitated corpses
in an account from the early 16th
century one particularly
impatient member of the crowd rushed
forward
snatched up a newly headless corpse that
started drinking blood directly from its
severed neck
as though chugging the world's most
gruesome yard of ale
a similar thing happened when charles
the first was beheaded for treason
now his blood was some serious grade a
merchandise
not only did it come from a person
killed by violent means
but in those days a monarch's touch was
fought to cure the swollen lymph nodes
caused by tuberculosis
it was a double whammy a miracle cure
all if ever there was one
and as soon as charles's head was parted
from his shoulders
the crowd surged forward to bathe in his
blood
picture the club scene from the film
blade only without the vampires and
dance music
apparently the executioner even made a
bit of extra cash on the side by selling
blood-soaked sand and locks of the
king's hair
charles the first son the
unimaginatively named charles ii
might well have been tempted to join the
blood-spattered crowd given half a
chance
because he too was rather partial to a
bit of corpse medicine
going so far as to require the recipe
for distilled powdered skull
from physician jonathan goddard possibly
concerns that
powdered skull sounded a little macabre
charles wisely opted to give his new
remedy a catchier name
the king's drops these drops were hugely
popular throughout the 17th and 18th
centuries
and came to be seen as something of a
panacea apparently curing everything
from
nervousness to dysentery it was even
believed they could prevent
death if administered at the very moment
of death itself
but there's just one small problem with
that theory
when charles ii was dying his doctors
began
frantically filling him with these drops
not to mention shoving several enemas up
his royal backside
and guess what he died
the popularity of the king's drops was
no coincidence because
according to the wisdom of corpse
medicine the human skull had some very
desirable properties
even the moss that grew on top of it
known as osnia
was potent stuff with the power to cure
the nosebleeds in powdered form
lord high chancellor of england sir
francis bacon
claims that if you rubbed the blade of a
weapon with osnia
you could somehow heal any wounds it had
caused
personally i think it would just be
easier to not cause the wound in the
first place but
it's to his own the stuff inside our
skulls was considered pretty useful too
in fact physician and alchemist john
french described a very tasty sounding
brain tincture in 1651's the art of
distillation
which leads us to the next installment
of everyone's favorite cadaver cookery
show
42's corpse recipes step 1 take the
brains of a young
man that have died of violent death
together with the membranes
arteries veins nerves and all the pith
of the back
step 2 bruise these in a stone mortar
till they become a kind of pap step
three
once mashed cover the brain paste in
spirit of wine
and leave it to digest in horse poo
delicious one of the most popular
ingredients of european corpse medicine
was egyptian mummy which took the
continent by storm
a whole host of different products
appeared on the market in a short space
of time
treacle of mummy balsam of mummy and
its most popular form mummy powder
otherwise known
as mummier mummia was available in
apothecaries
all across the continent and used for
all manner of ailments
stomach ulcers broken bones blood clots
poisoning bites joint pain
in fact it was so popular that
pharmaceutical giant
merck still lists it as a product in
their archives
along with some genuine samples the
problem was
mummies were quite tricky to get hold of
especially if you lived a fair old way
from egypt
so fraudulent mummies made from animals
criminals or the poor soon became a
thriving trade
some physicians were even forced to
create their own
one such process was recorded by german
physician
johann troider in his 17th century
medical team
pharmacopoeia medico kaimeka which leads
us nicely onto our third and final
installment
of fortitude's corpse recipes courtesy
of dr schroeder himself
step one take the fresh unspotted
cadaver of a redheaded man
because in them the blood is thinner and
the flesh more excellent
make sure he's aged about 24 and has
been executed or died of violent death
step two let the cops lie one day and
night in the sun and moon
but the weather must be good step three
cut the flesh in pieces
and sprinkle it with myrrh and just a
little aloe
then soak it in spirited wine for
several days
and hang it up for six or ten hours
step four soak it again in spirits of
wine
then let the pieces dry in dry air in a
shady spot
until they're similar to smoked meat and
will not stink
perhaps the most horrifying thing about
medicinal cannibalism however
is the hypocrisy well okay the whole
eating dead human beings bit is
probably the most horrifying bit but
then it's definitely the hypocrisy
europeans of the time saw nothing wrong
with munching on a bit of cadaver for
their own health benefits
but they were quick to reinforce
negative stereotypes of native americans
by suggesting they practiced cannibalism
catholics were also criticized by
protestants
for their belief in transubstantiation
at the idea
that the communion bread and wine
literally turned into the blood and body
of christ
in the mouths of the devout but
considering the popularity of corpse
medicine
it's highly likely a fair number of
protestants when nibbling human offcuts
of one sort or another
to cure their ills whilst judging their
fellow christians
for doing the same thing to the son of
god in the hope of washing away their
sins
but according to anthropologist beth a
conklin
who studied cannibalism extensively as
one does
including spending time with the wary an
amazonian tribe who practiced
cannibalism until the 60s
the whole practice of cannibalism is
rather more nuanced than you might think
the worry for example practiced two
different forms of cannibalism
one related to war where devouring a
recently dispatched enemy
was seen as a way of expressing anger
towards them and
one related to funerals where eating the
flesh of a recently departed loved one
was a way to express grief and affection
to the worry digging a big hole in the
ground
and lobbing the corpse of someone you
love inside to slowly rot away
is as disturbing an idea as cannibalism
is to you and me
the idea that cannibalism wasn't always
as barbaric as you might think
is perhaps best represented by the
mellified man
a legendary medicinal substance created
by
literally mummifying a person in honey
what makes the mellified man unique
within corpse medicine
is that the person would submit
themselves to be mellified willingly
for the benefit of their community when
they sensed the end was near
they would eat nothing but honey for a
month
at which point even their excretion
would turn to pure honey
as you can imagine when you've succeeded
in turning yourself into a human bottle
of squirty honey
death soon followed the body would then
be placed in a stone coffin full of
honey
which when dug up a few hundred years
later
would have turned into hardened candy
and would be used to treat wounds and
fractures
by taking a small amount internally my
even winnie the pooh didn't eat so much
honey that he started cheating it
as europeans started getting slightly
more civilized
using things like knives and forks
washing at least once a week and
generally deciding that cadavers weren't
the most hygienic things to have around
the house
medicinal cannibalism eventually started
to go out of fashion
and i'm sure we're all quite glad about
that right it's easy for us to look back
from our cozy vantage point here in the
21st century
and label this practice as disgusting
even barbaric
and fair enough if a friend invited you
over to dinner and you found out their
auntie brenda was on the menu
you'd probably run from the house
screaming but
are we really above using parts of dead
bodies to cure
ourselves even today in fact we aren't
even all that picky about making sure
the bodies are dead
before we start borrowing bits of them
after all
if you've lost a lot of blood you'll
gladly accept a transfusion
and then there's organ transplants of
course whether it's a heart from a very
generous recently deceased donor
or a kidney from one of your living
nearest and dearest
this idea doesn't tend to make us queasy
at all
organ trafficking has even become a
problem in recent years
due to high demand and short supply and
it's estimated that over 10
000 transplanted organs are bought every
year
mostly harvested illegally from living
people between 2001 and 2003
more than 100 kidney transplants were
illegally carried out
by saint augustine hospital in south
africa
in 2005 the kidneys of chinese prisoners
were sold to british patients
and in 2002 a huge operation was
uncovered in india
involving almost 2 000 illegal
transplants
from poor and migrant workers with a
value of around 32 million dollars
and although not quite corpse medicine
some of us modern types
aren't above dipping a toe in the world
of monumentally disgusting treatments
like
urine therapy a practice backed by
pseudoscience
which was first popularized by british
naturopath
john armstrong in the 20th century after
reading drink waters out of thine own
system
and running waters out of thine own well
in the bible
armstrong decided this was probably
god's way of telling us to drink our own
piss
and to this day some people are known to
indulge in a bit of
piddle quaffing former prime minister of
india
muraji desai was a long time advocate of
urine therapy
and even gave an in-depth interview on
the subject
on 60 minutes actress sarah miles drank
her own urine for three decades
believing it immunized her against
various allergies
and boxer juan manuel marquez was filmed
drinking his own urine by hbo
during a training session before his
fight with floyd mayweather
he lost by the way so maybe urine
doesn't have magical properties after
all
oh and how could i possibly leave out
survival expert bear grylls
who quite happily guzzles down his own
urine
like it's a particularly fine
chattanooga bap
so yes maybe we shouldn't be too
judgmental of our ancestors
i mean if you knew a loved one could be
cured of a terrible illness or even
saved from death by offering yourself up
post-death as an all-you-can-eat buffet
you'd be more than happy to wouldn't you
i know i would
well as long as i'm cut respectfully of
course and preferably by a gourmet chef
eat me medium rare or not at all that's
my motto
and thanks for watching thanks again to
keeps for sponsoring this video
don't forget to try it out using the
link below